mon rejoint sur ce plateau pierre
servant bonsoir spécialiste des
questions de défense coloniale de
réserve auteur de 50 nuances de guerre
aux éditions Perrin également au en
édition poche merci d'être avec nous
Julien Theron nous a également rejoint
ancienne ion à Sciences Po spécialiste
des conflits des relations
internationales auteur de Poutine la
stratégie du désordre c'est co-écrit
avec Isabelle mondreau du monde est
séché Talandier bonsoir à vous également
nous avons également à Bruxelles
sandrogosi il n'a il va arriver euro
député le groupe rinou qui va donc nous
rejoindre avant justement de démarrer
cette discussion je voudrais qu'on
écoute à nouveau Vladimir Poutine
la meilleure solution à cette question
serait pour que nos collègues de
l'Occident ne perdent pas la phase comme
on dit que les autorités ukrainiennes
renoncent à l'heure adhésion futur à
l'OTAN
que les autorités ukrainiennes mettent
en place l'idée d'un statut neutre de
leur pays triste
[Musique]
du côté de Wagner Poutine les accords de
mines ce que n'existe plus la Russie
reconnaît donc une version élargie des
deux régions séparatistes de l'est de
l'Ukraine et puis surtout finalement
elle annonce que
l'Ukraine n'existe pas que l'Ukraine
devrait se démerittéraliser se dit
militarisme et pardon oui effectivement
on est vraiment à mi-chemin de nos deux
livres pardon la stratégie du désordre
50 nuances de guerre on est en plein
dedans donc on est vraiment sur un
volcan là toutes les toutes les voies
sont possibles j'en vois 3 pour ma part
une dans laquelle l'admire Poutine comme
un joueur de poker menteur prendrait sa
mise à savoir le fait qu'il est qu'il
est maintenant présent militairement
dans le bon basse il y était déjà mais
là il serait officiellement et puis
continuerait des opérations de
cyberattaque pour casser l'Ukraine ça
c'est un scénario le second scénario
c'est une relance au poker menteur de
Vladimir Poutine c'est-à-dire le fait
d'aller à la conquête de la partie du
don-basse qu'il a en gerbé dans la
reconnaissance des républiques
sécessionnistes mais qui font partie du
territoire ukrainien comme le reste
d'ailleurs et là à ce moment-là on aura
au risque d'avoir une confrontation
militaire directe entre russe et
ukrainien vous avez parlé de Mario Paul
qui est effectivement un scénario et
puis on a un troisième scénario
catastrophe qu'on ne peut pas écarter
ces chemins faisant vraiment la volonté
d'aller plus loin c'est-à-dire de
Poutine mais très faisant tapis pour
continuer sur la métaphore du du poker
et alors là c'est vraiment l'ouverture
sur tous les dangers de guerre
c'est-à-dire prise de Kiev allez sur
Kiev ou construire toute une série de
provocations d'attaques de
déstabilisation pour essayer de mettre
en place les conditions d'un Maïda une
révolution de bydad à l'envers c'est à
dire qu'il y ait
des manifestants prorus des attentats
des provocations des déstabilisations
c'est une des éléments que les
Américains ont mis sur la table vous
savez que les Américains depuis des mois
et des mois ont une stratégie qui a pu
surprendre ceux qui suivent mal ce
dossier en prenant la décision de mettre
sur la table des documents classifiés
secrets
ils mettent pas tout sur la table parce
qu'évidemment si vous mettez tout sur la
table vous risquez de dévoiler puisque
comme de personnes Gambert sur le fait
qui pourrait y avoir même au Kremlin des
des agents qui renseignent les
Américains ce qui a permis aux
Américains d'avoir une une lecture très
claire moi je ne suis pas infiltré au
Kremlin vous non plus et je renvoie les
téléspectateurs aux émissions
précédentes qu'on a fait ici ça fait
déjà plusieurs semaines qu'on a annoncé
ce ce-là
effectivement de scénario attendus
depuis plusieurs semaines mais
je crois qu'il y a une chose extrêmement
importante c'est ce discours dans ce
discours il y a un nombre considérable
aujourd'hui celui d'hier et celui
d'aujourd'hui
les deux ensemble avec un nombre
considérable d'éléments c'est la
première fois qu'on lit l'existence
d'une nation par exemple on l'avait
annoncé au Kremlin on avait écrit le
président russe avait écrit un essai ou
plutôt un pamphlet devrait-on dire niant
l'existence de la nation ukrainienne
dans l'histoire et là on nie aussi
l'existence de son état on y on avance
tout un tas d'éléments absolument
déraisonnable en disant que va attaquer
la Russie qui va avoir des missiles
nucléaires en Ukraine on lit ça une
question djihadiste enfin on prend
l'intégralité avec des petits clins
d'oeil sur les armes de destruction
massive aux Américains en 2003 donc on
prend tout un tas d'éléments et ça c'est
vraiment un discours qui fera date on
avance
considérablement dans la volonté de
déstabilisée il faut bien comprendre que
non seulement il y a d'en basse mais le
gambas encore une fois c'est les deux
petites régions à l'intérieur du Damas
puis le reste du dommage puis l'Ukraine
regardons aussi que il y a quand même un
nombre considérable de troupes en
Biélorussie donc il s'agit bien d'une
crise de la Russie en Ukraine et en
Biélorussie face à un accident qui est
quand même passablement attentiste par
rapport à tout attentiste vous dites
pourtant ils ont pris des sanctions en
tout cas l'Union européenne a pris un
certain nombre de sanctions à
l'unanimité me semble-t-il d'ailleurs
pierre servant ses sanctions elles
peuvent être efficaces on attend
d'ailleurs d'une minute à l'autre Joe
Biden qui va faire un discours où il va
également exposer un certain nombre de
sanctions ce n'est pas assez fort comme
réaction
alors il faut il faut être clair je
crois que très clairement personne chez
les Européens les pays membres de l'OTAN
et les Américains les Américains faisant
partie de l'OTAN personne ne veut mettre
des militaires et des armes importantes
en Ukraine pour faire face à la Russie
il faut quand même rappeler à un élément
qui est pas un point de détail c'est que
la Russie c'est une puissance nucléaire
la France les États-Unis la
Grande-Bretagne qui sont aussi au sein
de l'OTAN sont des puissances nucléaires
donc en fait cet élément-là gèle la
possibilité de rentrer militairement en
Ukraine pour aider les Ukrainiens donc
très clairement ça a été annoncé c'est
pour ça aussi que Poutine fait tout cela
il sait que personne n'ira mourir pour
pour Kiev donc après il reste les
sanctions vous avez posé la question
je pense que ça ne changera rien pour
pour deux raisons d'abord ce qui est
très frappant et je vous rejoins pour
avoir suivi effectivement toutes les
déclarations de Poutine d'avoir aussi
entendu par la bande les propos que
tenus Macron de retour de Russie vous
avez un personnage qui est perdu pour le
monde de la rationalité il est l'Élysée
quand même parlé d'un discours paranoïa
psychiatre mais c'était la sensation que
j'avais donc c'est pour ça que les
sanctions ne l'atteindront pas parce
qu'il est persuadé d'être dans le juste
dans le droit de sa mission bécanique et
deuxième raison de seconde raison c'est
que les Russes sont déjà sous sanctions
depuis alors là les Américains les les
Européens annoncent des sanctions
majeures mais ça ne fait rien moi juste
un mot je me souviens de discussion avec
des officiers certes dans les années 90
en Bosnie-Herzégovine qui disait mais
vous connaissez rien au slave plus vous
nous tapez sur la tête plus nous
résisterons
au député du groupe réunion Europe bon
j'imagine que vous n'êtes pas tout à
fait d'accord avec ce que vient de dire
pierre servant vous donc qui est à
l'origine aussi de ces fameux sanctions
européennes qu'on aimerait bien un peu
décrypter avec vous manifestement elle
vise 27 personnes ou groupes
virus qui sont ciblés dont des banques
qui financent des opérations russes
oui oui 27 27 oligarques disons qui sont
liés des opérations économiques et
financières russes mais aussi tous les
députés de la Douma elle est à 151
députés de la Douma qui ont adopté cette
acte qui est illégal et violation
flagrante de droit international avec la
reconnaissance des deux républiques
séparatistes on Ukraine et aussi avec
d'autres mesures des
sanctions économiques et commerciales
vis-à-vis des territoires des de
République qui sont sous contrôle russe
et russes en Ukraine et avec des
limitations pour pour la Russie au
marché des capitaux financiers
économiques
européens moi j'ai je crois que il y a
trois éléments qu'il faut souligner dans
cette situation très grave
les éléments sont qu'il y a une unité
parmi les 27 Poutine à la échoué
il a espéré que comme ça a été dans les
passé les Européens
se voient divisé et cette fois-ci elle a
réponse des Européens a été
une année il y a aussi assez sanctions
s'ajoute la décision de l'Allemagne que
moi je veux saluer comme tout le monde a
salué des disons suspension de
l'autorisation pendant ce stream 2 la
question du gaz entre la Russie et
l'Allemagne je crois que ça aussi c'est
un signal très important et qui aurait
été impensable à cause des divergences
entre les Européens du passé donc de
d'un côté il y a unité des Européens un
travail des coordinations très étroites
entre les Européens les Américains les
Canadiens les Britanniques et il y a
aussi un une solidarité concrète
financière et des soutiens d'autres très
forte vis-à-vis de l'Ukraine après c'est
que j'entendais j'ai entendu en studio
des Poutine moi j'ai des partages et
c'est vrai que c'est un discours entre
idéologie paranoïa
ma surtout c'est au-delà de la paranoïa
c'est un discours qui est totalement
inacceptable 2022 parce que les discours
et l'action de se faire d'influence la
volonté des Poutine et pouvoir décider
pour les autres on prend des décisions
qui ne sont pas amis pour des mains ni
pour après-demain comme l'avenir
européen de l'Ukraine ou l'avenir à des
l'Ukraine très lointains de l'OTAN cette
logique dans laquelle il y a seulement
comme dans les 19e siècle les rapports
des forces se laissent faire d'influence
est totalement et totalement
inacceptable et de ses points de vue je
crois que la première réaction réaction
importante mais je crois que ces
sanctions qui sont ciblées et
progressives
efficaces ces sanctions parce que ce
n'est pas la première fois que les
européens prennent les sanctions contre
les Russes contre Vladimir Poutine
ça va être dissurance
ils se rendent d'autant plus efficace si
il y a pas si il y a
face à
une poursuite des actions des actions
des provocations de la part des Russes
elles pourront être augmentées et si en
même temps ce que j'appelle je crois
c'est tout à fait nécessaire les
Européens c'est donc un sanction des
compensations pour les économies qui
européennes qui ont soufflé plus parce
que dans le passé vous savez les
sanctions n'ont pas été efficaces parce
que parce qu'il n'était pas assez forte
n'était pas assez forte parce qu'il y a
des économies qui sont très exposées
quand on décide de sanctionner quelqu'un
on lui fait mal mais on s'est fait mal
nous-mêmes surtout quand c'est
économique et financière si on va on va
dans la direction dans laquelle les
Européens pour la première fois
organisent un système de compensation
économique pour les économies les plus
exposées je pense à celle à l'italienne
à la française
pour pouvoir poursuit pour suivre dans
l'augmentation des sanctions si on voit
on voit que les Russes ne récupèrent je
crois que dans ces cas-là on semble avec
les sanctions britanniques américaines
cette fois-ci elle pourrait elles
peuvent être efficaces on va écouter
justement je vais boire je vous
interrompre sans négocier on va écouter
Joseph Borel justement le chef de la
diplomatie européenne
nous avons convenu de cibler 27
personnes et entitées
ceux qui ont menacé les Ukrainiens les
entités qui les ont financièrement ou
matériellement soutenus et qui en ont
tiré des bénéfices
du secteur de la défense ensuite pour
avoir joué un rôle dans les actes
d'invasion ou de déstabilisation
contre l'Ukraine ainsi que les banques
qui financent les décideurs russes et
autres opérations dans ce territoire
c'est plus fort que d'habitude c'est ce
que vient de dire Sanogo aussi l'Europe
unie des mesures inédites des un
mécanismes de compensation le mécanisme
de composition de compensation il est il
est je crois très constructif l'unité
européenne également c'est pas la
moindre des avancées celle de l'OTAN est
également mais il faut bien comprendre
que ces sanctions là il faut savoir quel
objectif on veut atteindre les sanctions
qui ont été prises depuis 2014 n'ont pas
fonctionné si on veut que pourquoi
elles ne sont pas assez puissantes il y
a ce qu'on appelle le principe
d'incitation une santé en anglais si on
met pas l'incitation suffisante pour
atteindre objectifs que l'on veut ça ne
marchera pas
quelle est l'incitation en fait si c'est
pour embêter un petit peu le pouvoir
russe en lui réduisant un peu sa voix sa
puissance économique ça a marché ils
n'ont pas pu par exemple reconstruire en
Syrie parce qu'il n'avait pas assez de
moyens mais si on veut qui rende la
Crimée à l'Ukraine et qu'il se retire
désormais de du dombasque ça n'a pas
fonctionné non seulement ça n'a pas
fonctionné ça les a même pas dissuadés
d'aller encore plus loin dans le
donbasse et de préparer une nouvelle
attaque contre le reste de l'Ukraine je
pense que les sanctions sont nécessaires
je pense que le mécanisme de
compensation est effectivement très
constructif il faut effectivement saluer
l'unité européenne sur ce dossier là le
gestalement mais il faut bien comprendre
que ça n'est pas du tout assez en fait
on vit dans deux conceptions qui sont
parfaitement différentes à Bruxelles et
à Moscou à Bruxelles on est dans le
domaine du soft power on pense que des
sanctions vont réussir à inverser la
tendance et à Moscou on est passé non
seulement de ce qu'on appelait la
galerie bride avec des instruments quand
même assez disons largement de
camouflage avec sans un signe
avec un soutien confidentiel en dans le
don-basse mais là on est en train de
passer à une phase militaire
conventionnelle de la part de la Russie
et il faut bien comprendre que l'Europe
ne doit plus jouer uniquement sur son
sapin plus ça veut dire faire quoi alors
techniquement ça veut dire avoir des
choses qui vont bien au-delà par exemple
ces sanctions elles sont certainement
nécessaires mais elles sont pas non plus
considérables 27 députés de la Douma
vous imaginez bien que ça va pas changer
énormément de choses le président Biden
alors peut-être qu'on va entendre
quelque chose de nouveau dans un instant
mais enfin il avait quand même dit qu'il
allait pas sanctionner immédiatement la
Russie elle-même enfin je veux dire
c'est quand même assez assez hallucinant
et ce que comprennent les Russes c'est
par exemple l'équilibre de la puissance
militaire si la livraison d'armes de
défense de défense en titanque et
anti-aérienne ça ils ont compris qu'à ce
moment-là ce serait peut-être plus
compliqué d'avancer en territoire
ukrainien ça veut dire plutôt militaire
alors la réponse
Okon
c'est le fait de renforcer tous les
moyens militaires de l'Ukraine il faut
rappeler que l'Ukraine quand elle a
perdu la Crimée quand elle a été envahie
et la Crimée récupérée par la force
après un plébiscite bidon façon
soviétique l'armée l'armée
ukrainienne c'était 10000 hommes 15000
hommes et aujourd'hui à 200000 hommes
elle est armée donc il faut aller dans
ce sens-là un point que je voudrais
ajouter je suis très frappé ça fait
plusieurs années que dans les contacts
que je peux avoir avec des
responsables de services de
renseignement occidentaux ils disent la
chose suivante la Russie est devenue un
état voyou pas le peuple russe la Russie
est devenue un état voyou dans son
comportement dans sa façon d'éliminer
des opposants des dissidents par en
utilisant des produits chimiques des
armes chimiques par l'utilisation de
Wagner dont on voit tout le rôle en
Afrique et et ailleurs donc le
comportement de Poutine est extrêmement
préoccupant mais juste pour rebondir sur
l'Europe générale tout ce qui a été dit
l'Europe la construction européenne
c'est toujours faite dans la difficulté
dans la douleur là je pense que ça va
permettre à l'Union européenne de
progresser de se souder de réfléchir
peut-être aussi au moyen militaire
européen qui sont tout le temps
brillonnaires où il manque de volonté là
vous savez nous vivons l'histoire
les méthodes que effectivement on peut
être utilisées auparavant napkasi en
océité du Sud c'est de territoires
Géorgiens en fait dans Moscou a reconnu
d'abord l'indépendance est-ce que c'est
le même scénario un petit peu
travail sur scionnel la méthode
poutinienne les textes de Poutine il dit
les choses et puis il a fait des choses
donc ça passe par des cyberattaques
d'abord pour complètement désorganiser
le pays adverse vous en avez eu sur le
plan institutionnel civil sur le plan
militaire ça va s'accentuer dans les
jours qui viennent après c'est la
construction de toute une scénographie
et d'un discours sur le thème je suis
une force de paix et je vais au secours
de nos frères russes qui sont menacés de
génocide ici ou là et après on rentre
militairement dedans et il poursuit dans
ce sens-là et je suis très surpris de
voir le nombre de personnes qui ont été
dupes de ce discours pendant des
semaines et des semaines c'est un
classique de Poutine Poutine aujourd'hui
je termine par là et convaincu que le
droit les règles de droit ce que
proposait président Macron une
architecture de droit de sécurité le
droit est pour les faibles et le retour
de la force aujourd'hui c'est celle de
la Russie et de la Chine et sachez que
la Chine regarde tout ça avec beaucoup
d'attention parce que le don basse c'est
taïwani est-ce que finalement ce n'est
pas un sacré revers pour Emmanuel Macron
est-ce qu'il y a encore une place pour
la diplomatie alors que Vladimir Poutine
a dit que les accords de Minsk c'était
terminé
les choses en perspective
en retournant en novembre novembre 2021
et de la crise ukrainienne parlait Joe
byeden et Vladimir Poutine en ignorant
les Européens à Genève
du moment où Macron a pris la tête de la
présidente du Conseil de l'Union
européenne et il a Rémi les Européens
dans le jeu donc je crois que il est
difficile de critiquer Macron pour son
initiative et son courage c'était avant
que les Européens étaient nulle part et
c'est grâce à son action que les
Européens jouent un rôle aujourd'hui ils
ont fait preuve d'unité ils ont adopté
des sanctions que dont on verra
l'efficacité mais qui sont très
importantes et qui sont la première
vague de sanction première avec sanction
cibler progressive et les sanctions vont
avec la diplomatie les sanctions doivent
servir à
prendre répondre à des contacts répondre
que t'as donc de dire que vous me
demandez c'est un réveil pour un Macron
non c'est la confirmation que la
proposition que nous faisons et qui est
manuel Macron fait que il est temps
aussi pour les Européens j'y réponds ce
qui était dit en ce moment qui a mis sur
la table des pays longtemps la question
de l'autonomie stratégique et des
Européens qui depuis longtemps arrêté ce
qui disait Bismark que la diplomatie est
un arme c'est un peu comme la musique ça
reste vraiment qui a posé sur la table
la question des réponses Europe
puissance moi je suis d'accord qui qui
se bat la semaine dernière on a adopté
et c'était ma collègue Nathalie Loiseau
qui était était en charge on a adopté
pour la première fois au Parlement
européen un rapport sur la politique
sécurité et défense qui dit exactement
ce que vous dites au studio que l'Europe
aujourd'hui doit renouer avec la notion
de puissance
l'époque de la naïveté de sofa est
révolue
c'est un passage fondamental c'est un
passage fondamental parce que jusqu'à
maintenant les Européens ont refusé de
travailler sur la défense ont délégué à
l'OTAN mais même le temps a été
revitalisé par Poutine
l'année dernière semaine longtemps dans
les dernières semaines arrêt pris mais
qu'est-ce que vous voulez et l'Ukraine
l'Ukraine longtemps l'aide il y a la
piste faciliter à travers elle reçoit du
soutien militaire il y a une assistance
ma co-financière on a donné un milliard
de son million donc c'est que vous
disiez on aide l'Ukraine pour contrer
les cyberattaques ce que vous
démondiez en studio vous disiez il faut
aider l'Ukraine on est en train de
développer
l'article 5 de l'automne la clause
assistance mutuelle ne vaut pas pour
l'Ukraine mais tous les tous les tous
les les autres font des partenariat
économique et militaire sont activés
pour l'Ukraine évidemment la situation
est grave mais il faut pas il faut pas
il faut pas il faut pas il faut pas nier
le fait qu'il y a quand même et des pas
en avant aussi sur la prise de
conscience de l'Europe et cela et sur
les sens de l'orgence de l'Europe avec
des mesures comme ça qui ont été
présents aujourd'hui j'ai encore
beaucoup de schémas à faire mais la voix
la voix me semble tracée par Emmanuel
Macron oui mais alors justement Julien
Theron pour rebondir sur ce qui vient de
dire sans négocier est-ce que la voix
n'est pas tracée plutôt par l'agenda de
Vladimir Poutine parce que c'est pas ça
qu'il faut ce problème les deux
sandrogozy a raison de dire que il y a
des efforts qui sont faits l'autonomie
stratégie est un concept plus un concept
qu'une réalité en terme de construction
capacitaire européenne par exemple ou de
convergence en terme d’armement mais
c'est déjà quelque chose il a répondu
dans ce qui descendrogosie effectivement
on progresse mais moi je me souviens
bien quand même des termes qui sont
employés au moment de la diplomatie
française a raison tente le dialogue
avec Moscou mais les termes qui sont
employés c'est de détente c'est le terme
de détente au moment où la France parle
de détente à Moscou
les plans sont là les Américains nous
expliquent on a déjà une compression
capacitaire avec l'armée qui a pris qui
est prête à avancer ce qui est le cas en
fait la diplomatie elle est toujours
nécessaire elle est encore nécessaire
aujourd'hui bien sûr la porte doit
rester ouverte mais il faut savoir ce
qu'on met derrière comme un citation
comme moyen derrière pour soutenir cette
diplomatie et sans drogozy a raison il y
a des moyens déjà qui sont déployés en
aide à l'Ukraine etc mais il faut faire
monter très largement parce qu'on n'est
pas dans ce monde postm auquel on
croyait dans les années 90 en pensant
que la démocratie allait s'étendre on a
même pas réussi avec les sanctions
européennes de 2014 a empêché que la
Russie
envahissent encore plus le crâne on peut
dire que c'est pas un très grand succès
à empêcher justement que Vladimir
Poutine envahit
très sagement disait que c'était un
premier train de sanction et qui
pourrait y en avoir d'autres donc on
imagine bien le travail des députés
européens dans cette perspective de
faire monter la pression c'est une
stratégie assez sage mais ceci dit il
faut bien comprendre que il faut aller
beaucoup plus loin pour les empêcher de
le faire je pense que très sincèrement
si c'est juste le train de sanction
alors ça n'empêche absolument pas les
Russes de poursuivre et d'attaquer
l'intégralité de l'Ukraine
oui oui non effectivement alors le point
c'est que d'un côté vous avez Vladimir
Poutine qui fait la gendarme alors oui
oui dans le sens où il a pris la
décision de l'option militaire en
octobre de l'année dernière il a pris
alors avec des variantes et après il
nous a baladé avec des séquences
diplomatiques totalement bidon balader
de vous dites
ça veut pas dire que nous les démocrates
même si on a le sentiment de se faire
balader il faut essayer de jouer cette
carte moi je peux pas reprocher à tout
les Européens les Américains qui ont
essayé malgré tout de mettre un pied
dans la porte d'essayer de pousser de
tirer de l'avoir fait on nous sommes des
démocraties c'est-à-dire à la fois il y
a une vertu une beauté de la démocratie
et une femme une faiblesse intrinsèque
quand vous avez en face de vous une
démocrature démocratie dictature
d'ailleurs qui est de plus en plus
dictature tout court et de moins en
moins démocratie dans l'histoire
d'ailleurs on a connu d'autres exemples
on est des avantagés alors Poutine a
fait son agenda mais il a été gêné par
plusieurs choses d'abord les Américains
ont eu raison de casser le discours
poutinien en balançant en permanence
parfois de façon un petit peu
caricaturale en disant
oui oui mais c'est dramatisait
aujourd'hui
si vous voulez rétrospectivement non
c'est dans la
ils ont encore une fois que il y a des
diplomatie c'est une chose mais parfois
on a plus de ils ont plus donné le
sentiment c'est mon avis de faire preuve
un peu de naïveté par rapport au dessous
des cartes mais sinon pour revenir à
votre question soit est-ce que c'est
Poutine qui décline son agenda il a des
gains pour l'instant psychologique de
terreur etc il va à l'échec et il a
quand même ça a été très bien dit tout à
l'heure il a quand même remporté ce
succès de réveiller l'OTAN qui était en
mort cérébrale et qui est reparti
Poutine a essayé de diviser de
marginaliser les Européens et de
négocier qu'avec l'OTAN entre
parenthèses l'OTAN c'est 30 pays dont 21
pays européens l'Union européenne donc
l'OTAN c'est aussi l'Union européenne et
de ce point de vue là si vous voulez les
otaniens les Américains et les Européens
ce sont pas laissés avoir et donc
Poutine à face à lui un front beaucoup
plus solide beaucoup plus cohérent alors
qu'est-ce qui va se passer dans les
jours qui viennent on est toujours des
avantagés quand vous avez d'un côté un
dictateur qui est capable d'aller
jusqu'à la violence regardez la violence
contenue du discours du personnage le
non-verbal et de l'autre côté des
démocraties qui sont dans la négociation
dans la recherche de de compromis
parce qu'on a notre envoyé spécial et
correspondant dans la région de l'hiver
crack que l'on retrouve à Kiev Gulliver
bonsoir alors justement quelles étaient
les réactions à Kiev aujourd'hui le
président Zelenski me semble-t-il a vu
le président estonien comment réagit-il
pratiquement posé je dirais en disant
que l'Ukraine maintenant pense que
effectivement c'est l'escalade militaire
qui est dans les plans de Vladimir
Poutine et ce que Vladimir Poutine a dit
ce soir sur la reconnaissance de ces
états dans leur frontière définie par
leur soi-disant constitution alors ça
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui fait
froid dans le dos parce que c'est la
confirmation que Vladimir Poutine
soutient ces séparatistes dans leurs
intentions d'essayer de conquérir des
villes comme Mario Paul slaviant
crémators toutes les régions de Donetsk
et de loin ce que dans leur intégralité
territoriale administrative
se prépare à la guerre est-ce qu'il y a
un changement de discours de ce côté là
oui oui c'est ce qu'il dit tout le temps
ceci dit il a aussi dit que il n'allait
pas introduire la loi martiale tant que
ce n'était pas la guerre qui l'os est
encore croire que il n'y aurait pas la
grande guerre la guerre qui atteindrait
d'autres parties de l'Ukraine peut-être
même qui attendraient jusqu'à Kiev mais
tout le pays maintenant se prépare à la
guerre vous n'avez qu'à rendre au centre
de recrutement militaire il y a il y a
beaucoup de monde aussi les magasins où
on peut acheter des choses comme des
casques des gilets par balles et tout ça
rupture de stock total partout
clairement le pays qui est resté pour
une grande partie des Ukrainiens en tout
cas très réticente à croire qu'il y
avait vraiment ce risque tellement de
gens qu'on a rencontré ces dernières
semaines ces derniers mois qui disaient
non non j'y crois pas ou non je regarde
pas l'actualité je lis pas le journal
les gens qui après 8 ans de conflit
n'avaient pas envie de croire que ça
pourrait être ça pourrait devenir
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup pire là
maintenant il commence à se rendre
compte que il faut se préparer merci
Gulliver West avec nous sans drogosie
une réaction peut-être justement à cette
mobilisation
ukrainienne à la fois donc un espoir
finalement du côté du président
ukrainien parce que finalement il
accepte il est heureux qui est des
sanctions du côté des Européens et
probablement aussi des Américains et en
même temps cette préparation militaire
qui effectivement fait froid dans le dos
oui mais tout d'abord les sanctions je
les ai les sanctions sert à faire
retravailler la diplomatie les sanctions
doit servir à
redémarrer un dialogue même si très
difficile avec la Russie et vous savez
dans ces crises internationales il n'est
jamais trop tard pour s'arrêter et
l'objectif c'est de faire arrêter les
Russes mais de l'autre côté donc d'un
côté il faut utiliser les sanctions pour
convaincre les Russes à s'arrêter pour
convaincre les Russes que tout acte
ultérieur sert à encore plus sanctionné
de l'autre côté il faut comme je disais
faire preuve des pleines solidarités à
l'Ukraine avec l'assistance donc
dont on a parlé c'est que j'ai entendu
du studio de l'OTAN et tout à fait vrai
Poutine est en train de perdre et perdre
la bataille stratégique peut-être il est
en train de gagner la bataille de
l'opinion publique à Moscou peut-être il
est en train de gagner la bataille de
l'opinion publique dans parmi
l'anciennice Lab il y a quelqu'un qui
lui prête un oreille peut-être trop
attentif il faut être très clair avec
les Serbes et avec Belgrade sur le fait
que certaines déclarations certaines
ouvertures
vers Poutine sont inacceptables pour un
pays candidat à l'Union européenne il
faut être très clair avec les Slaves et
les serres de la républication
à un certain discours des Poutine mais
du point de vue stratégique Poutine est
en train de perdre sa bataille l'OTAN
s'est réactivé la Suède et la Finlande
on dit que comment ça a évaluer
éventuellement la possibilité
d'inadhésion à l'OTAN on a et l'OTAN est
a été très clair sur les faits que les
révisionnistes des Poutine
rencontre et limite infranchissable dans
les Pays-Bas qui sont membres de l'OTAN
donc du point de vue stratégique il est
en train de perdre sa bataille et nous
devons continuer à faire cette preuve
des solidarité envers les et d'unité en
tant qu'Européen mais je dirais on tombe
dans le contexte de l'automne plus au
sens plus large parce que je crois que
aujourd'hui on a fait c'était une
journée importante un signal important
des mesures importantes mais peut-être
que d'autres mesures encore plus dures
seront nécessaires et il faut continuer
avec cette unité j'ai quoi que les
Européens sont en train d'apprendre des
laissant important et nous sont en train
de vivre véritablement des chapitres de
l'histoire européenne dans ces heures
dans ces jours Julien la bataille
stratégique la lumière Poutine peut-être
c'est pas encore sûr on est en retard on
est très en retard effectivement
sanogozère raison on progresse dans
notre unité dans notre dans notre
position unitaire mais fondamentalement
on est présent ça on est très en retard
effectivement ces sanctions là je ne
crois pas du tout que sanctionner 27
députés de la Douma suffira même à les
ramener à la table de négociation le
Sénat vient d'autoriser l'envoi d'une
par le président l'utilisation de la
force armée russe à l'étranger alors
c'est pas que dans le don-basse
nécessairement ça peut être dans toute
l'Ukraine on n'est pas du tout dans un
moment de rétractation dans une
ouverture diplomatique de la part de la
Russie on a aucun signe qui nous donne
ça tout ce qu'on a c'est de dire les
sanctions européennes on s'en fiche pour
être poli pour paraphraser un
ambassadeur russe et fondamentalement ce
que dit le président zenenski pourrait
être écouté c'est à dire que ce train de
sanction il arrive toujours apostériori
on arrive toujours en disant on va aller
punir on va aller punir avec déjà de
petites choses qui ne donc ne renverse
pas la tendance mais en plus toujours a
posteriori il y a une position plus
proactive qui voudrait de dire écoutez
tant que vous ne retirez pas la
construction capacitaire formidable dont
les Américains nous expliquent à 190000
hommes maintenant autour de l'Ukraine
tant que vous ne la retirez pas là on va
vous sanctionner et on enlève les
sanctions quand vous retirez votre
troupe là ce serait beaucoup plus
proactif vous voyez ce serait beaucoup
plus énergétique comme comme réaction
tout en restant sur des méthodes de
software donc il y a des solutions comme
ça et là on toujours un peu en retrait
et en retard car ça avant vous êtes
d'accord avec ça je trouve que c'est une
très très bon point mais vous avez tout
à fait raison mais encore une fois
stratégique nous sommes
je suis d'accord avec le fait que il
aurait fallu prendre des sanctions assez
lourdes dès que ce dispositif militaire
dans cerclement dans les airs sur terre
et en mer ces positionner autour de lui
en disant écoutez j'aimais trop tard
faut avancer etc tout ça est compliqué
mais on aurait pu le faire mais deux
points d'attention très rapidement vous
savez que ces dernières années il y a
régulièrement des frictions entre des
appareils des avions de combat russes ou
des sous-marins ou des bâtiments et ceux
de l'OTAN c'est à dire que Poutine passe
son temps ces dernières années à flirter
avec les lignes rouges à rentrer en
confrontation j'avais retenu le chiffre
sur une des dernières années de 400
sorties aériennes des forces de l'OTAN
pour aller en quelque sorte raccompagner
les avions russes qui s'approchaient de
de de de
400 sorties aériennes qu'est-ce qui va
se passer aujourd'hui c'est vous qui
m'avez appris tout à l'heure autour du
Charles de Gaulle notre porte-avion il y
a eu des avions de combat russe qui qui
ont ces manœuvres d'intimidation le
problème c'est que le jour où vous aurez
un crash un accident je rappelle que
dans l'histoire récente il y a un avion
de combat russe qui a été abattu par les
Turcs ça provoqué une crise majeure dans
le ciel de Syrie donc le point
d'attention c'est celui-là je crains à
des regains de tension et des risques
d'accident la seconde chose que je mets
sur la table c'est est-ce que au Kremlin
est-ce que dans le pouvoir russe tout le
monde est d'accord avec Poutine
vous pensez effectivement qu'il pourrait
y avoir un incident tel que le décret
pierre servant c'est ça en fait
le côté dangereux
les dangers sont plusieurs et les
dangers sont énormes la situation est
grave il faut évidemment pas
sous-estimer la gravité de la situation
mais c'est que j'ai entendu sur le temps
c'est ce qui me pousse à à vous dire que
c'est le mois de ce point de vue Poutine
est en train de perdre la bataille
stratégique parce que c'est provocation
ils ont amené à une augmentation des
troubles de l'OTAN à la frontière
orientale il y a des Allemands il y a
des Italiens il y a des Américains il a
il a amené à l'OTAN à renforcer
énormément même dans les déclarations la
pleine solidarité pour les membres de
l'automne qui sont dans la frontière
orientale c'est provocation n'ont pas
affaiblioton ces provocation n'ont pas
affaibli la présence des troubles de
l'auto frontières orientales ces
provocation ont amené l'OTAN à renforcer
sa présence et puis en même temps
n'appartient pas à l'OTAN donc elle fait
pas partie en fait
de l'article
et que nous avons dit clairement abouti
nous devons continuer à les dire c'est
que il y a plusieurs façons d'élargir le
ton mais sans doute l'automne ne peut
pas s'élargir on demande on demandant
l'autorisation à Moscou et en laissant
Moscou décidé pour les peuples et les
pays européens qui veulent ils veulent
pas adhérer à l'OTAN donc qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire que l'Ukraine
l'Ukraine a le droit donc de candidater
à l'OTAN toujours parce que
manifestement Vladimir Poutine encore
demandé aujourd'hui à ce qu'elle reste
neutre à ce qu'elle ne demande jamais à
rentrer à l'OTAN dans l'OTAN nous avons
parlé ouais nous avons parlé d'un bon
studio encore et l'autre fois aussi de
ça vous m'avez déjà posé cette question
et
les premières savoir que les ragissement
de l'OTAN et l'Ukraine n'est pas un ni
pour aujourd'hui ni pour demain mais
c'est que nous devons nous pouvons pas
il y a plusieurs façons d'élargir
longtemps la seule façon qu'on peut pas
accepter c'est que
oui s’élargir ou pas et selon les
souhaits d'un État tiers et selon les
souhaits de la Russie ça c'est
inacceptable et ça nous devons être très
clair et le temps être très clair sur
ces points parce que c'est vrai que
Vladimir Poutine la redit aujourd'hui le
mieux serait que l'Ukraine renonce à
l'OTAN et deviennent neutre alors
l'Ukraine a été neutre pendant 30 ans ça
lui a valu donc deux invasions de son
voisin qui s'était engagés à ne pas
l'envahir donc on peut dire que
neutralité de l'Ukraine a eu un succès
relativement mitigé deuxième point moi
je suis parfaitement d'accord avec
Sandro Gosier le principe il est là et
tout le monde est d'accord en fait dans
l'Union européenne et dans l'OTAN ça
n'est pas il n'y a pas de droit de veto
de la Russie pour quel que soit les
intégrations d'ailleurs comme par
exemple la Russie ne demande pas
l'Ukraine le droit d'intégrer
l'Organisation du Traité de sécurité
collective sa propre alliance de défense
donc ça c'est le principe de
souveraineté que d'ailleurs la Russie
dit respecter donc c'est très important
mais la question encore une fois c'est
ce qu'on fait pour ça et là
en ce moment vous voyez on ne fait pas
assez parce que ça ne suffit pas et une
fois que l'Ukraine sera prise par les
Russes ce sera trop tard pour que
l'Ukraine demande son intervention à le
temps ce que je voudrais dire aussi
c'est que ça ne s'arrêterait pas là et
derrière monsieur le disait très
pertinemment derrière il y a la Serbie
et la République à serbska c'est à dire
la République servent de
boston-herzégovine qui entend faire ses
sessions dont certains militants ont été
aussi en lien avec l'Union des
volontaires du don-basse
la Russie et la Serbie partage un
partenariat sécurité et militaire avancé
il leur livre des armes aujourd'hui et
il y a aussi la question du Kosovo et
tous ces états-là ne font pas partie de
l'OTAN et ça peut être une question
fondamentale vous savez que
sandrogosie a raison fondamentalement
l'OTAN a mis des hommes dans ces pays de
l'OTAN on est protégé par ce parapluie
au tanien mais vlanir Poutine est
suffisamment intelligent pour se dire là
je peux faire une invasion
conventionnelle de l'Ukraine avec des
forces parce que l'OTAN justement ne
bougera pas et demain faire quelque
chose aussi de plus non conventionnel
avec des cyberattaques avec une
déstabilisation sociale politique comme
déjà on le voit avec une certaine
ingérence en Europe donc ils
utiliseraient d'autres atouts parce que
évidemment la Russie ne va jamais
attaquer de front l'OTAN on est trop
fort pour eux et aussi il y a cet
équilibre nucléaire dont vous parliez
donc il y a un équilibre des forces bien
sûr ils vont jamais attaquer comme ça de
front la Pologne avec des troupes
américaines en face bien sûr mais en
revanche déjà il y a des territoires qui
déstabilisé il y avait la question du
Gotland vous savez il y a eu une crise
en Suède où les Suédois sont fait
ridiculiser parce que il y a eu des un
survol d'avion russe ils sont moqués des
suédois en disant bah en fait vous ne
bougez pas militairement parce que
c'était je crois le week-end de Pâques
donc il y a pas eu de réaction militaire
donc je veux dire bon il y a déjà des
territoires où c'est quand même un peu
tendu même au sein des pays de l'Union
européenne ou de l'OTAN mais aussi même
si c'est des pays au sein de l'OTAN il y
a d'autres méthodes de déstabilisation
on va juste retrouver encore Gulliver
crag à Kiev Gulliver justement quand
dit-on à Kiev de cette entrée de cette
volonté d'adhérer à l'OTAN aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs est-ce que les Ukrainiens le
souhaitent majoritairement je vous avais
déjà posé la question mais c'est
intéressant de le savoir aujourd'hui
oui le pourcentage des Ukrainiens selon
les derniers avantages souhaitant entrer
dans l'OTAN a légèrement augmenté à la
fin de l'année dernière je pense qu'on
était à 58% maintenant ça a dépassé les
60% si je sais plus si c'était à 60 ou
62 % donc c'est une claire majorité sans
être une super majorité il y a quand
même une partie une minorité importante
en Ukraine qui ne pense pas que ce soit
une très bonne idée d'adhérer à l'OTAN
mais c'est la politique affichée du
gouvernement qui a été inscrit même dans
la Constitution par l'ancien président
petropochenko certes qu'il a fait à un
moment où il cherchait désespérément
qu'a dit l'élection de 2019 il pensait
que cela marcherait ça l'a pas aidé à
être élu c'est volody beerselinski qui a
été élu à la place mais voulons dire
zalinski une fois élu tout de suite
clairement dit que il avait aucune
intention de changer de cap que lui
aussi voulait amener l'Ukraine vers le
temps est d'ailleurs il multiplie cette
demande d'entrer dans l'OTAN à chaque
opportunité depuis le début de cette de
cette crise avec la Russie quand les
forces ont commencé à s'abasser au port
de l'Ukraine au printemps 2021
pierre savant donc effectivement ils
veulent rentrer dans le temps les
Uraniens ça
Vladimir Poutine n'obtiendra pas ça
toute façon les Occidentaux ont déjà dit
que c'était une ligne rouge oui mais ce
qui est clair et ça a été dit ici c'est
que
l'activisme frénétique et inquiétant va
dire Poutine ne va faire que stimuler
les envies d'aller rejoindre l'OTAN pour
ce pour se protéger le risque aussi que
je veux souligner c'est que
Poutine encaisse aujourd'hui des gains
tactiques mais son échec stratégique est
inscrit dans sa démarche il va il va
perdre sur le plan stratégique et le
risque c'est qu'il se lance dans une
surenchère nationaliste en permanence on
y est pour essayer de troquer auprès de
sa population le fait que le pays va se
trouver quand même plongé dans des
difficultés parce que les sanctions vont
rajouter un certain temps de difficultés
et donc sa porte de sortie ça va être de
faire ce qui est fait depuis des années
des années de raviver les souvenirs de
la grande guerre patriotique contre
l'Allemagne choisi il faut savoir que
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs Poutine l'a
utilisé à plusieurs reprises sur le
gouvernement de Kiev en parlant de
néo-nazi à la télévision russe quand il
y a des reportages sur Kiev vous avez un
drapeau nazi qui apparaît donc vous avez
toute cette construction et plus Poutine
va échouer dans sa stratégie plus la
tentation de l'extrême de la dérive
autoritaire de l'hibernationalisme va se
développer et comme vous avez des
concentrations d'armement aujourd'hui
qui sont extrêmement importantes dans la
région on n'a pas parlé de la Syrie ou
les rues sont des des bases de la
présence en monétaire année qui commence
à poser des problèmes notamment en mer
Noire à la Turquie qui est pourtant d'un
certain côté à la fois alliés des Russes
et alliés des Ukrainiens donc quand on
parle d'histoire je crois qu'on est tous
d'accord là-dessus nous sommes rentrés
dans une période historique sans compter
ils n'en ont pas parlé des Chinois enfin
on a juste évoqué mais vous avez les
Chinois aussi en embuscade là-dessus
là-dessus qui explique avec Vladimir
Poutine que les deux seules démocraties
authentiques du monde c'est la Chine et
la Russie je laisse chacun en juger
merci beaucoup pierre servant d'avoir
été avec nous Merci à VOUS Sandro Gossi
d'avoir participé à ce débat merci bien
sûr aguiler crag à Kiev et puis merci à
vous tous nous avoir suivi vous reste
avec nous sur France 24
[Musique]